the great thing about this opencv course
is that you can follow along from any
computer
without installing any software by using
google colab in your browser
mspa who teaches this course makes it
super simple to follow along if you
already know some python
hello everyone welcome to this opencv
tutorial series
here we will be using python in google
collab to create
opencv projects understanding the basics
of opencv we will understand the color
profiles
doing edge detection image manipulation
these are all simple applications
of opencv and then gradually move into
the
intermediary applications like color
detection writing
drawing shape detection we'll also try
to do some
projects using the knowledge that we
have embossed in this particular
tutorial
to create ball tracking face recognition
and so on this tutorial series is
designed for people who are beginners
intermediary and people who just want to
enhance their knowledge
in the opencv field we are using golab
which will allow us to
create these applications right off of
the website on the google collab
library we don't need to worry about
downloading some dependencies installing
libraries
making sure things run or not having it
on collab makes it very easy
plug and play for us with that let's get
started
hello welcome to lesson one i'm going to
quickly make the screen
big and i will also upscale this thing
so the visibility is right good for you
in the description you can open up this
link and it will take you to this page
and the basically the first step we're
going to do is simply
run this clone so we're just cloning the
repository we're just
downloading all the files that we need
for this program
it makes our lives easy if you go into
this folder you'll see this opencv
tutorial folder created for us
and it has some sort of images that we
will be using
for this particular set so the first
step
the first lesson we want to look into is
changing a
color profile of an image so the first
thing you want to do is
import opencv and that's the
mother or father of everything of all
the images
you want to download opencv first make
sure
opencv is happy and it's take case takes
care of all our images
to the best of its extent now we also
want to display the images
and since we're using google colab it's
in order to display it
right in the browser there is a
different function and for that purpose
we will import
from google because google had created
this
patch for opencv and you say
google collab dot patches
so you have patches from google cola
patches
import cv2 i am show
then the purpose of this guy cv2 im sure
is just
to take your image and display it on the
browser
as simple as that now you have opencv
and you have opencv
i am sure now what do you need you need
the
images to work on so the first thing is
to read the image and i'll say
okay i have an image and show me how i
read the image
so opencv has this command
called i am read and this is basically
stands for
image read this image read guy can
take whatever image you have and just
read it in the program in this python
application
what does imd need from you it only
needs
the path of the image file so
where is our image located our image is
located
this is the color.jpg this is the image
that i am interested in
and it is available inside this images
folder
of color.jpg so we will say
okay i have my image
it is in the images folder bracket and
then you slash
and you put down color dot jpeg but that
is my
image so i am read just needs for you to
guide
and let them know where the image is
stored i'm just saying it's under images
color dot jpeg so it's as simple for now
now let's try to read this image let's
try to display this image
for now so we can use this cb2 im show
command
and will do i am show and this i am show
only needs you to tell what image you
want to show
and in our case we just want to display
this image
so we see this is the image you want to
show us
once you have this just go ahead and run
this
and it should open up the image for us
you can see it's a very colorful
very vibrant display image for us right
here in the browser
now i am interested in what is the
dimensions of the image what are the
properties of the image
and for that purpose let's not display
it again
we write a opencv
tell me what is the dimension what is
the property of the image
that is stored under the function under
the variable called
shape so i will run this and
it displays this function in this number
and what is this what what does this
stand for so 476
and 640 are nothing but the number of
rows and number of columns
or the width and the height of the image
and this number three
represents the number of channels that
are available in the
image now since this image is a colorful
image
it has three channels which is nothing
but the
red green and blue channel
and that is what defines a colorful
image
so this is basically a colorful image
now the first thing we will look into
since we are talking about colorful
profiles or changing the color of the
profile of the image the first thing we
will look into
is making an image grayscale
now grayscale image what is this
it's basically a black and white image
now let's see how opencv can do it for
us
we will call a new image called gray
and we will say hey grey image
make this colorful image turn into gray
for us
how would you do it you're just going to
open cv2
and opencv has this amazing function
called as cvt color
and this color function is capable
of converting the color of any image
that you give
so you need to just let the function
know what
image that you need to provide in this
case
you say our colorful image from the
previous section
please convert that into gray for us
so we say image but it also needs to
know
what kind of color you want yes i know
you have
given me the image the colorful image
but what do you want in return from me
so for that purpose we say hey opencv
convert it into a color from color
to gray so we say convert
color in caps luck
and then underscore we say hey
opencv convert it from bgr
to gray so we just say
this and it converts it for us and we
see bgr because
our original image is in the format of
blue
green red all the three channels
separate
and we convert it into a grey image
coming down let's display this image for
one second now let's see what does the
gray has in store for us
and let's run this and voila
our colorful image is now turned into a
grayscale
now you might ask hey mister you had a
very beautiful colorful image
why did you bother converting it into a
grayscale image
why does why do you even need to do that
aren't you spoiling the image aren't you
going to spoil the program
what is the purpose of converting into a
grayscale image
the purpose for that is these three
channels
you can see the colorful image had three
channels and these three channels store
information about the red color
green color and blue color that is
a lot of information for us
when you're going to be using opencv
algorithms and
computer vision programs you have to do
complex processing pixel level
processing
you're going to be opening each bit each
and every bit
of the image and that's too much of
information for us
so in order to reduce that one of the
techniques
is to reduce the number of channels so
like this
colorful image had three channels if you
were to display
and ask opencv hey opencv
give me the number of what is the shape
of this gray color shade
gray color image and if you print this
you can see that the colorful image had
three channels
and the black and white or the grayscale
image has
no channels you can see there is nothing
available here
because it's only one one matrix
all by itself it doesn't have any
channels
you have reduced you have compressed all
those three channels
into one channel which is defined by a
gray color
profile so you have reduced
information you have reduced the number
of pixels you have made opencv happy
because
now it doesn't need to handle three
different channels for your images
just one image this is one channel and
that's all it needs to take care of so
you're making opencv happy
you're making your computer happy
because it doesn't have to load
so many bits of information for you
and this makes life easy for you and
for the program so let's go into
the basics now we have the grayscale
image
let's look into another print another
type
and that is the hsv image
now you might ask okay so we have
we took out all the color profiles we
took out everything we needed from the
color
images now we brought them into a gray
image
but what if i was interested in color
i'm a colorful person
and i am interested in identifying
different colors in my
image and that is my project but you
made it into grayscale
now how do i how am i going to work on
it
well to answer it for that is your hsv
image and this hsv image or this hsv
channel
is capable of holding all the color
profiles
under one channel now what do i mean by
that
to appreciate that fact remember this
your colorful image had three channels
right blue green and red
the hs3 image will also have three
channels
but the channel that defines the color
is only present in one bit so i'll
explain what that means
but let me say hey opencv i'm going to
create a new image called
hsv and for that purpose i want you to
convert
my original image i'm going to use again
this
convert color profile function and i'm
going to pass opencv the colorful image
that we had
image and we're going to let hey opencv
this original image that i have
converted into
a hsv image
hsv color
bgr to hsv
and if i just print the
shape of this hsv hsv dot
shape and let's run this
so you can see hsb also has three
channels
so what are we doing then
well hsv stands for
hue saturation and variance
and the hue is defining all the
color profile in the image all the
colors
that are available blue green red
everything all the colors of the rainbow
are going to be
available in this just one channel
called
each so if you can control if you can
pinpoint h to give you red color
you can also pinpoint it to give you
yellow color
green color blue color so this hsp guy
the hatch channel of this guy can hold
all the colors of your image
so previously this colorful image had
three channels
and in order for you to define a color
yellow
you would need all the three channels to
define
what a yellow color looks like but
a hsv image can only use your h
channel to define what color you need
and that makes your life in detecting
colors
very simple very easy and
very very easy for the computer to
process
so your complex algorithms that we will
look into the future
will be very easy to run you might ask
how does this hsv image look like well
you don't want to see it but i'm going
to do it anyways
and you might regret let's run this
and you can see that this hsv image
looks nothing like the colorful image
nothing like the grayscale image it has
its
own legend and it's
it's running it's it has an own property
it has its own way of displaying images
and that is what we are interested in
we are going to look into the h value
the s value
and the v value separately to define the
color that we are interested
with that we come to the conclusion of
our first chapter which is changing the
color profiles
and these are the color profiles that
are going to help us in
our later projects welcome to lesson
number two
here we're going to look into what edge
detection is all about
so the first step is to go ahead and
import opencv
so we can see we can take care of all
our manipulations image manipulation
that we're going to do right now
and we have this image which is right
under this directory if you go into
opencv tutorial
you have this images folder and under
images folder you have this image
color.jpg we will work with that image
today
we will say hey opencv i want to read
this image and i want to save this
in this variable called image so image
is equal to cv2 im
read and you need to tell opencv
what is the image file path
so in our case we saw that it was under
the images folder
and it's called color.jpg so that is the
file path for us
we just go ahead and write down the
image path name which is under images
bracket and just specify what stay after
the slash
and you say color dot jpeg
you are now specifying what is the image
that you want to read
once you have this if you want to just
simply display it you can use cp2
i am show and that's how you display it
but since we are not able to use
we are using the collab version we
cannot directly use cv2 dot i n show
and for that purpose we will import
something called as
or from google
google has this patch that created in
order for us to use the
cv to imp i am show we will use google
collab dot patches import
cv2 i am shown we are just importing cv
to im show
and we will say hey cv2 i am sure
please display the image
for us we just specify the image and if
we
run this it will display the image for
us
right here in the browser we can see our
colorful image is right
up and running for us now let's
understand
let's go into the edge detection so
we have this image you know let's for
now we'll
comment it now let's make it into a
canny image
we say can image and the scanning image
is nothing but the
edge detected image we're going to be
using a edge detector called
scanning edge detector i'm going to be
using this function
from opencv which says
a opencv pv2
please do the kanye edge detection on my
image
so opencv has this function called canny
you just need to specify what is the
image
okay i have the image the canon edge
detection
also requires you to specify
the size of the filter that you're going
to be using
so the filter size in our case will
specify hey let's go to be
150 by 200 it doesn't matter what filter
you're using
you can always test it out and see what
kind of a result are you getting so if
there's no hard and fast rule behind the
150 and 200 which i mentioned here
you can always test it out and see and
now
we can simply display this but before we
display
there is an issue canning image does not
run does not run by its own it needs to
run on a grayscale
image like the grayscale image that we
learned in the previous lesson
where we were converting the grayscale
using the color bgr to gray
we need to convert our image into a
grayscale image
before we do anything so let's copy this
let's copy this line from here and come
back to our can edge detection now we
know what is the purpose what is
what is one of the uses of grayscale
image we save this here
and we convert our image into a gray
image and we specify the gray image to
canon
because scanning is only able to work
on grayscale image it only assumes that
the image has
one channel and for that purpose we need
to make sure
you're only providing one channel
grayscale images
and let's see how this image runs out to
be
now you can see the whole image is gone
and it's only specifying the
edge profiles of the image isn't that
amazing
that is what the canon edge detection is
capable of
there are a few more adjectives there
are a few more things that we can do
with this
we have the candy image and it has it's
able to detect
all the linings able to detect
everything all the edges that are
available in the image
but say we were not interested in
everything we were only interested in
the highlighting features of the image
because right now it's very difficult to
understand what this object is
even about so we can use some filtering
methods
and for that purpose let's import numpy
import numpy as np
and numpy is our brother to opencv
who is able to do some matrix
manipulations for us
which is also very very much similar to
what opencv does
in fact np can also be
uh another format of opencv because it
does also works with matrices
but opencv has already made very things
very easy for us
but we are not going to ditch it we're
going to use it simply and run our
application with the help of opencv
now you have np the next step
we're going to look into and understand
erosion
and dilation we'll say erosion
and dilation right here so let's first
do erosion of our image now
we can do erosion by saying hey
erode my image which image
the canon image eroded so that
you can remove some of the filters that
i'm not interested in
erode the image by using opencv's
your road function and this erode
function
is capable of taking your image which is
the
canon image you have the kanye
underscore image
but it also needs for you to specify
a window size because this window is
going to
move over your image and wherever that
window
matches or falls into the property of
erode
it will eradicate it oh you know what i
just found my mistake so i missed
the e over there and we are also needed
to specify
the window size which is also called as
the kernel
the kernel equal to np which since we
are going to be using
numpy to create our matrix then kernel
is a small window a small matrix
and it's going to be a matrix of ones
and we'll give it a size of maybe
pi by five and we'll say np
is of unsigned integer of bit size
eight but that's basically specifying
what our image is going to be looking
like and this five space five by five is
nothing but the tuple
so it should be under brackets and you
have your kernel
defined right here we use the kernel
into our
erosion format we say kernel
and it can also take you can move the
window over the image
multiple times right now we're just
interested in one time so we'll say
iterations equal to one so
erosion going back to the function there
are a few things happening
so the erosion function is able to take
the image that you're interested in
it also needs the kernel and it also
needs the number of iterations
you are going to specify it so let's
display this image as well pb2im show
erode image so let's
erode image and now run this so we are
going to run this image
and for some reason we're getting an
error and the error for here it says
that
as a substitution consider cv to
underscore i am show
and we as the user of opencv on the
desktop
we used the dot i am show function
let's convert that into the underscore
and let's run this
and you have a new image which is which
has
nothing but basically eroded everything
so let's reduce the kernel size and
say two by two and
let's see what kind of a result we will
get
so it has some information you can see
some dots available
of course it's taking out most of the
information
and now you might ask why do we why do
we even need to do this because it's
taking out all the information that is
available in our image
let's make it by one by one and see if
it can display
some more information yes it's
displaying a little bit of more
information but if you compare with the
previous image there is not much of a
difference
and it makes us think or doubt ourselves
about
why do we even use erosion well erosion
is used
in order to reduce the noise level in
the images
and it also comes and it's very much
useful when we are
when we can pair it with dilation so
let's look into what dilation stylation
is nothing but the
opposite of erosion so let's go into
dilation uh let's uh
maybe comment this out for now and we
say this is
erosion
and this is going to be dilation so
dilation also needs the kernel
yes so we can put maybe the kernel on
the
edge side so we'll put the kernel
right before everything so it's the main
guy because it uses
it uses both erosion and dilation so
we'll have
kernel in both now we say hey dilated
image
use open series dilate function
dilate and use your can
image let me move this out of the way
so you're using opencv's dilate function
and it also requires the
kernel that we created
the kernel and we also use the
iterations
equal to one so what we did is
we're using the dilate function which is
very similar to what the arrows
function is now we're using it again on
the canning image
we're making the kernel where you're
making use of the same kernel
and we are using iterations of one by
one
let's see what we can get if we have the
kernel size of
five by five and let's
display this for us
i am sure opencv dilate image
let's run this and we can see this is
the
any kanye edge detection image and
this is the dilated tv what is happening
here
you can see that the edges or all the
edges that were visible here
now they have been emphasized they are
made more they are increased or you can
say dilated
they become very big now now if we were
to use erosion after dilation
let's uh let me remove this kernel we
don't need the kernel or we can keep it
for your purpose
that's fine and let's do erosion
after dilation so we have here dilated
image and we'll use the dilated image
instead of the canning image and then
display our eroded
image so let's run this
so you have for the original can image
again
then you have going down you have your
dilated image
and now you have your eroded image so
you can see there is a difference
between the
canyh image and the eroded image but
there's little bit of doubts here
so if we increase
let's see what else we can do to make it
more simpler for us to understand
so we have the canning image in the
eroded image
we are basically converting we are
basically uh making
or displaying them one after the
other what if we do it horizontally
stacked so we have this
np dot head stack we use display
this is the image that is going to be
displayed and numpy has this function
called hedge stack
and h stack is going to take three
values and our values are
the can image we have
the dilated image and we have the
eroded image we use all these display
images
and we say cv2 i am sure
display this image instead of displaying
the eroded image instead of displaying
the dilated image
instead of displaying the canning image
altogether
we will display all of them under one
horizontally stacked
we just run this and we can see all the
three images
right here in front of us so you can
easily compare what is happening to the
original canon image
the edge detected image has made it
dilated so it becomes big
and now you're eroding some parts of it
so it can become
more and more visible and you're just
trying to
basically erode some of the more
abundant information available here
so this is more about erosion and
dilation and
the number of the number one use of
anti-age detection with use of
erosion and dilation is in the process
of
making lane detection applications so
you
you have a robe you have a picture of a
road or you have
a video of a road and you are interested
in understanding where the lanes are
available
and for that purpose you want to use the
line detection
the edge detection and then provide
dilation and erosion
if you if there are any kind of noise
you want to remove
so the erosion and dilation is nothing
but to use
or work with noise for our purpose
and uh that helps us that helps us in
making the image more visible so that
you're not
focusing on the un necessary information
but focusing on what we need maybe it
could be the edges
maybe it could be a certain region
within the image so you can specify your
filter size and then
focus on the area that you are
interested in hello everyone how's it
going
today we're looking into image
manipulation
now image manipulation has a variety of
things that you can do
if you're just going to open cv and type
in image manipulation
you'll open up this open cvs program and
let's look at image calculation of
opencv
if you just go into image processing and
open
you will see that it consists of color
spaces changing color spaces
doing some sort of geometric
transformation thresholding smoothing of
images which is nothing but
all these noise and blurring images
morphological operations which include
of
erosion dilation and opening closing etc
erosion dilation is something if you
recall in the previous
video if not if you haven't seen them
i'll put the link in the description
uh you can look into this erosion and
dilation
and this will be this is basically
removing the noise or adding
or emphasizing those pixel values
similarly you have image gradients you
have canny edge detection
uh you also have image parameters so
these are all different types of
image manipulations that you can do and
we will look into some of these
important ones which we need to know for
sure
yeah into a subsequent uh chapters but
right now
let's look into one particular aspect
which is denoising
or which is also called as removing the
noise removing the issues
that you across you come across in these
images
now in order to run this once you open
the collapse link
you can go ahead and run this code which
is in the very top and
it's basically the github clone and
you're just cloning the repository that
we need here
so it'll take a few seconds and we'll
clone the repository and if you open up
this
folder which is the directory folder
you'll have this opencv tutorial
and it'll have this images under images
today we have this new image called the
lion image
lion.jpg image and the reason we have
this lion.jpg image images because
i i wanted to choose i wanted to
get a very grainy and a very noisy image
and yeah animals because of the
amount of hair present on them it seems
to be very noisy on a camera
especially line with all the big hair
available on it
it becomes very nice we'll look into the
code and see how this image
really looks like so we have we're going
into lesson number three
image manipulation and let's read this
image for us
so we are importing opencv we're
importing
cv to our underscore im show and we are
also importing
numpy now let's look into displaying
this image first
the image equal to cv2
dot im read and we want to read the
image under the opencv folder because
our
image is under the opencv folder urban
cv
lion dot jpeg let me
maximize this a little bit so it's
easier for you to read
in fact i can close this as well now we
know it's under the
opencv images i think we are already
under the email opencv folder
we just need to be under the images
folder because
we already changed the directory right
on the beginning
if you see we have changed the directory
to opencv tutorial
so the cursor is somewhere in here we
just want to go under the images folder
so for that purpose i'm telling the
images that image which i'm opening
it's under the images folder the images
then you have the line.jpg so
this image should be read into this
folder in this variable called
image and once we have this image we
will now
display it we will say cv2 underscore i
am show
image and if we just run this
it should display the line image for us
you can see it has this big image and it
has so many hair on it
and it seems very noisy if you look it
from a camera perspective
from image perspective of course those
are the definitions of
uh the hair of the alliance i don't know
what it's actually called but
you can see the number of grains the
number of noisiness available here
now consider that okay
this is something noisy picture and
you're not interested in
looking at all this images looking at
all these hair profiles of the line
how do you remove this thing how would
you remove or blend
all these hair profiles into one and for
that purpose
we have something called as fast error
mean
denoising color and this is a part of
open series
denoising profiling so if i go under
opencv
image denoising you can see that it's
taking a grainy image and this is from
the website
or this is from the opencv's website so
it is a very grainy image you can see
the amount of noisiness
that's available and once you apply the
denoising filter on it
it removes the noise to a large extent
and how it's doing it is because it's
averaging the pixel it is taking the
mean of the pixel in that area
and whatever is available which is more
important it then
denoises it and just takes out what is
important for us
and this is what the denoising takes
care of first
we'll come here and we'll apply the same
denoising filter on
our image and uh the denoising filter is
looks like something like this
fast and means denoising
colored and it's the reason we're
putting colored is because this is
colored image
similarly opencv has something for
grayscale where you can do
more about binary images where it's only
black and white
and they have their own functions which
will act in a separate way
in this case we're using the colored
profile and we need to provide
the image that we want to do in our case
it is image
and these are all the filters that are
available so
because this is it's kind of a filter
it's kind of a window that goes over all
across the
image and it displays all these images
for us
so uh there is a filter which basically
goes through all these
images and then this is the size of
those filters the
these are the threshold values so all
these values are something
right now at this point you don't need
to remember what this is about
but when you're using this program this
particular
this particular function in your
real-time code or project
that may just play around these values
until you get the result
that you want now there is no hard and
fast rule in knowing what is correct and
what is wrong
because every size of every image is
different the project that you're
working is different
the type of uh images that you're using
is different the size of the images are
different as well
so all these values will differ from the
different images that you're using
in my case for this particular image
that i'm playing with today
if this particular value is worked out
and uh but it could be different for
different and we'll see how this thing
works a little bit as well now coming
down here
uh let's display this image so you have
the original image which
is the image and the destination image
which is dst
now you let's use a numpy to create a
horizontal stack of this so we'll create
a horizontal stack which we will be
displaying
and we'll call it as a display and
horizontal stack is basically
adding both these two images destination
and image and making it look like
one image so the numpy has a function
called h stack
and it can take two variables or two or
many variables of
similar size similar matrix size so we
can say okay
hey uh i want to add the image
and i want to add add the destination
together
and both of them please combine and give
it to me under this variable called
display so we have display come down
here
and we will use open cvs underscore iron
show
display and it will display this for us
let's uh comment this thing so we don't
we're not displaying it two times
because already we are displaying the
image and the destination
here for our case now let's come here
let's play this
and it should run both the commands and
it should give us the output
right here oops jumped up
okay so you can see both the images are
available here
and this is the original image which has
all this grainy profile of the lion
in this case you can see that all the
greens all the hair
are blended and they're joined and you
can only see the gradient color out of
it
and all the hair profile which was
basically defining the features of the
line here
are gone and it's only emphasizing the
gradient profile of this
so it's basically considered considering
all these hair profile as noise
and removing them and giving it out to
us so it looks like a more of a
cartoonish
cartoonish display of an image and
converting
it or cartoonizing the image but it's
kind of a
representation of those images here for
us so
uh now coming down here let's play with
these values a little bit
so you have 20 let's see what happens if
we do it as
five and let's run this again and we'll
see what kind of an output we get here
and since we reduce the size of the
window you can see
that the grains are now much more
visible there is of course a little bit
of
blurriness available here you can see
this portion here and this portion is
different whereas the long hair
available here
are also available here because the size
of the filter reduced and it's only now
removing small
small amount of noises because the
texture you see here on the nose
it has small noises and those noises are
being blurred out
however the big hair profiles that are
visible that are still visible in this
final image
and that's because you have reduced the
amount of the
filter similarly if we increase to this
thing say for example
we were to do 50. let's see what kind of
an image we make we may get
uh let's see even if we can even
recognize whether it's a
image of a line or not and you can see
that it's
fully blurred out there you can hardly
identify any kind of
features uh in this image and it looks
like
more of a painting without much uh
without much definition of the
original character and uh you can see
this this is
this thing more looks like uh something
from a 3d
something from a cartoonish drawing and
all these features all these things has
been
blurred out and it's only showing the
gradient of it
and that's how it affects all these
filters all these values
affect the value and similarly you can
play with all the other values
and see what kind of an image you get
out and uh this is
basically helpful when you're doing some
sort of image
or foreground extraction or background
removal
where you want to specifically
segment or specifically emphasize on the
objects and remove all the types of
noise available in the image and uh
that's how it's very helpful
so the way that with that we come to the
conclusion on
image noise removal hello everyone
welcome to lesson number four
here we're going to try how we can draw
shapes
and write text on images so opencv has
their own
drawing functions and own writing
functions and we'll see how we can use
that
to our own images the first thing you
want to do here is
import our opencv
so you can see we can take care of all
our opencv
overall manipulation functions
once you have image maximizes a little
bit
once you have open cv the next thing
you're going to be using in this project
would be numpy import numpy
as np and i'll go into why we're using
numpy
in a little bit we're also going to be
using
google collabs cv2im show so that we can
use and display the images right here in
the browser for us
we are importing from google collab
patches input cv2
underscore im show
so we have all these three libraries
right here
now normally we go into the
directory and right try to open one of
the
existing images but in this case
we will create an image from the scratch
from the basics
so the first thing we will do is we will
use
numpy to create a matrix for ourselves
so we'll call a matrix called img
okay so this is our matrix with img
and now what is numpy going to create a
matrix for us
a numpy has this function called
zeros and this zeros function is capable
of creating a matrix of just
zeros so the zeros function is going to
create
return a matrix which is just filled
with
zeros and with opencv language
0 is nothing but black color
so now since we could be using a
colorful matrix
we will create a three channel matrix
i'll go into that right now so
let's first define the size of the
matrix
we'll say okay let's call it a 5 by 12
and 5 by 12 matrix so it has about 5 12
rows and 5 12 columns so that's the
definition
of our matrix and this matrix
is also going to have three channels
these three channels are representing
the red
green and blue color of a colorful image
but in this case we know we are
initializing it with zeros
so all those three channels will
basically be
zero at the moment but we want that and
the reason we want that is
later on we can fill in the colors that
we want
so we have our matrix which is 5 by 12
5 by 12 and 3. and we are also going to
say
okay numpy this matrix is going to have
a property
where the numbers are going to be
unsigned integer
of byte size 8 now what does that mean
unsigned integer of byte size 8
means the range of the values inside the
image or inside the matrix
are going to be anywhere between 0
to 255 that is the meaning of
unsigned integer so basically you're
just defining
matrix and you're telling that this
matrix is yes it is zero in color
but later on in the future when you're
going to be
adding new colors it's going to add in
this range
only and it can take a range of values
only between this 0 to 256.
that's because colors are represented in
a 256
range which starting from 0 goes to 255.
so
you're just defining that this is
unsigned integer
okay now let's display this
let's see how this image looks like
we've been talking about
zeros we're talking about c black in
color
but let's actually see how this function
works oh you know what it should be i am
sure
we have our image let's display this
we have run this and you can see it's
nothing but a black and black color
image not even white black
black image altogether so we have taken
care of the image
and now our image is present so let's
try to do
some manipulations on it like some
drawing functions
so opencv has couple of drawing
functions it can do
draw or draw a circle for us it can draw
a line for us
a rectangle it can put text so the
couple of things that opencv allows us
to do
let's see how we can go about doing that
opencv has a function called
circle so we'll use the circle function
ross will call it as draw a circle
let's see how we can do that opencv has
this
function called circle cv2 circle
and this function can define you can see
it takes the
image name the center of the circle
the radius of the circle the color
the thickness the type of the line shift
and then it defines
gives out the result in your image
function
so this is what the circle function does
now let's define the circle function
needs the
image which is the img it also needs
the center of the coordinate of the
image so we will say
okay the center of our image in this
case
is going to be at maybe 100
and 100 so x and y are both hundred
okay good we have this
then let's the next step you want to put
down is the radius
we have the radius let's say maybe 50
okay
we have a radius of 50. next thing you
want to do
is the color so you want the color
now color is represented by three
variables
which represents the bgr value so in
this case let's
make it uh green color circle
we'll call it as because since it's
represented as bgr
where b is for blue g is for green
r is for red we will call it as zero
and since we want green color we'll put
green as 255 which is the highest value
and the red is again 0.
once you have the color defined the next
thing you want to do
is the thickness the thickness of the
line so the thickness is also
something you can define and we will
call in our case a thickness
of size 10 okay
so let's see how this function works for
us and then immediately after that we
are going to display our image
and let's run this and you can see
that now we have a circle it's a circle
which is green in color and it has a
thickness about
size 10. so
that's about drawing the circle you can
always play with these values these are
nothing too crazy about you can make it
a size
thickness of five and you can see the
thickness as radius
from the circle so that's pretty much
about this drawing a circle
once you have drawn the circle let's see
how we can draw a
rectangle again principally has a
function called rectangle
cv2 rectangle and this function
also takes something similar it takes
the
image it takes the points of the
rectangle
and it takes the color the thickness of
course the line time and the shift
and we can then draw the rectangle now
point one and point two it says that
it draws the rectangle between the two
opposite points so point one is on the
top left corner of the rectangle point
two is on the bottom right corner of the
rectangle
coming back here we will see cv2
rectangle
yes you want to draw the rectangle on
the image img
and you want to define the point one in
our case
the point one is going to be
should we draw at 100 by 100
no but that'll be intersecting with the
circle
so let's bring it a little bit away from
the circle
we'll call it as 200 by 200
okay so it's a little bit further than
the circle
and we are going to say that it's going
to end
at maybe 400 by 500 this is just
random you can choose whatever you want
to draw the point here is just to
understand
how we can draw these parameters these
rectangles and geometrical shapes on the
images
so we have point two defined now we want
to define the color
let's make this a red color rectangle so
we'll call it as
zero for blue 0 for green
and 255 for red
let's minimize this a little bit so we
can see what's going on in the other
part of the stream
so we have 255 we also want to specify
the thickness of the rectangle the
thickness of the rectangle is going to
be
five for example let's
run this and see what we can do on the
image
and now you can see that there is a
rectangle coming up
and this rectangle has about the same
thickness as we had for the circle
because both of them are
5. so once we have this circle let's
let's see what happens if we put the
same coordinate as the circle 100
by 100 same
0.1 and let's see what we get
and you can see a rectangle that is
intersecting the circle
and then it's also bigger in size
because the 0.2 has not shifted
let's bring it back to where we are so
it doesn't messes you up when you are
trying this code on your own
okay so we have the rectangle we have
the circle
what are we missing the line function
let's draw a line
so opencv has this function called
let me put down the comments here so we
know what we're doing here
draw a rectangle
draw a line okay so cb2 has a function
called
nine now line can also draw something
on the image and uh you know
a line can be defined between point one
and point two so as long as you know
where the points are
you can draw a line so you are going to
be using the image
the point one the point two the color
the thickness
by now you might get the pattern so it
first takes the image
it takes the parameters of the
coordinate of the geometrical shape
and the color and the thickness the line
temperature
is something that we're not looking into
but you can have a dashed line you can
have a broken line a dotted line
for different types of lines by default
it will take a solid line
come down to cv2 line so it takes the
image
and it takes the point one and we'll
call 0.1 is
some random value 160 by 160.
okay now what is 0.2
0.2 let's put it as a random value of
359
29 so you have 0.1 and 0.2
and this time we will give it a color of
blue color so we'll see 255
for blue 0 for green zero for
red so you have the blue color and we'll
give it a thickness of
again maybe three
and let's see how we can run this
we run the play button and there seems
to be an error because we've missed
the comma between the thickness and the
color
so we've specified that and now we can
see there is a line
drawn right here between point one and
0.2
so we have the line drawn we have the
rectangle
we have the circle coming down to the
last point
is how to write a text
on the image and we can draw a
text or we can put down a text on an
image
by using cv to
put text so it has a
cv2 dot put text function
and this function can put down this the
text that we want to put down but this
also takes the
information where it's going to be
putting it's going to be putting on the
image
it's going to take the text the text you
want to be
putting down the origin of the text so
the initial coordinate of the text
the type of font you're using the
size of the font the color of the font
the thickness of the font and then it
draws the text for us
and this text right here is going to be
a string
it's going to take a string value and
then display it on the
image for us so let's come down to cv2
put text and we will say okay the image
img is going to be using
to display the text and the text is
going to be
open cv and the next step is going to
define
the origin of the text and let's say you
want to be putting it at 280
by 150 so
we have defined the origin of the text
now we're going to be defining the font
phase
the opencv has some default fonts that
we can use
at the same time if you want to use your
own font
yes opencv does allow us to use some
external fonts
but you can see that it's giving me an
option of putting down
font underscore hershey complex
small duplex plane so it has couple of
options
let's go with what we have here and
we can put down okay font hershey
complex
you're ready for us and the next thing
you want to put down is the scale now
the scale is the size of the font
and we will put down just for the safety
we'll say 2 because we don't know how
big this text is going to be
we have 2 and then the next thing is the
color
now we've already used blue green and
red you can see
the blue is for the line the green is
for the circle and the red is for the
rectangle let's use something different
now
well we can put down blue as zero
we can have green we can also have red
i wonder what kind of a color this might
give out
now the thickness let's say the
thickness is two
and we can now display this
and see how we can what kind of an
output we can get
so you can see that it is generating
this text
opencv it's starting from the origin
that we have specified
but it's going beyond the size of the
image
that's because opencv does not know
from especially the font function does
not know where the image is
ending so it keeps continuing printing
the text on the image and if the text is
beyond
it simply truncates it but it does not
raise any errors so the only solution
for that
is you reduce your image you reduce your
text
so you can either make it as small as
text by making a size of
one okay if you made the font size is
one so it's within the scale
or you can also use or move your origin
instead of 280 you can say okay we'll
put it at the same point where the line
is so we'll say 160
by 160.
oops 160 and let's close the bracket
right here
and we'll put the form scale back to
size
now let's see you can see that's not
generating the open
cv it's of course on top of the line
original line
but it is at least within the image per
se
i guess that does the job for us in the
last
here we are displaying the image
for us so that's the simple function
these are simple functions that can be
used but again
they help us in displaying the data on
the images for us
we'll see in the future projects how
we're going to be using these functions
in our real-time projects hello everyone
welcome to part
two which is intermediate exercises of
this opencv tutorial series
and we are going to look into lesson
number one which is
color detection the first thing you want
to do
is come under the top of the most the
earliest thing
come here where it says cloning the
repository
and also changing the directory let's
run this function
by itself and we are only interested in
this just because we do need
this opencv tutorial folder and it has
certain
images and we're going to be using one
of these images here for our project
so let's come down here and let's look
into the intermediate exercises
and we are under color detection the
first thing you want to do
is import all the libraries that we need
and we need import cv2 we also need
numpy as np let me maximize
this a little bit so it's easy to read
so import numpy as nb we are also going
to be
importing the google collab library
for our display we'll say from google
dot co patches
import pv2 underscore
i am sure let me show you what i have
done here
so from google collab patches we are
importing pv to underscore im shop
now we have all these images where we
have everything in our folder
if you go back to this directory and
under the opencv tutorial folder under
the images
you have certain images and we are going
to be using
this image called shapes.png
so coming back here we will say okay i
open cv you know what i have this image
called
shapes.png and i want you to read it
for opencv to read this image we use
opencv
cv2 dot i am read
so opencv will tell me okay i'm going to
use i am read to read
but give me the file name what's the
file name
okay the file name is going to be shapes
dot eng but this shapes.png
is inside the folder called images
so i will also need to provide the
folder path
this images with the slash images
that shapes.png is where
the image is available for us
okay so that will read the image and it
will
save the image under the image folder
variable
now let's display this image by using
cb2 underscore
i am show image
and we just display this image here for
us
so we're just reading and displaying the
image okay good
let's run this and we can see that it is
displaying this set of image
it's a big image and which has all the
shapes
and different colors present in here
okay good
now coming back to the code so we have
the image right now and we are just
displaying it now
see if i was only interested in
particular colors
i have this blue color here let's let's
say that i'm only interested in this
blue color for now
okay so we come here the easiest way to
select
blue color is to first convert it into a
new
hsv image instead of a bgr image
currently image is a bgr image
it is represented
in blue green and red channels
okay now we want to convert this
image into a hsv image
so we have okay coming here
let's come down here let's convert this
into an hsv image and we'll call it hsb
image equal to pv2
convert color we used this function
in i believe it was lesson number two
it was right here in the
lesson number one i believe yes
it's changing the color profiles
we used it here for our convert color
bgr to gray bgr
hsv if you haven't watched that part go
back to the
page where it displays the hsp image we
have given description of what hsv
images
are and how do they look like coming
back
to the color detection aspect coming
here we are just using the
convert color function to convert our
bgr image
to a hsb image and this convert color
function
requires us to tell what's the original
image
the original image is the image variable
right here
and we specify the image one after that
we do need to provide what kind of a
conversion you're doing
now since we're going to be using bgr to
hsv
we're just going to say convert color
bgr to ray so we have pgr
to hsb i'm sorry bgr to
hsv so this function right here
hsv is going to be converting a bgr
image to an hsv image
now we have the hsv image let's
do you want this do you want to see the
hsp image
if you have watched the previous video
you don't want to do it but
just for the sake of understanding let's
run this
there seems to be a function error yes
because we use the underscore
uh we did not use the underscore instead
we use the dot version
so you can now see that this
hsv image is different it's different to
what's
available here this this original image
has different colors
for the different shapes but here it's
almost the same but it's not the same
mind you on that it's a little bit
different yes it is in yellow in color
but they have different color profiles
different ranges
but oh and we'll see how we can utilize
that factor
okay let's remove this
just play this so we have our color
image here
okay now what is the next step the
purpose of hsv is because
you are converting a bgr a three channel
image
into a hsp image where hue saturation
variance you represent the color profile
so you can now control the value of
hue to display what color you want so i
will say
okay i have this image it has different
colors and i'm only interested in this
blue color
so i can isolate this blue color in the
hsv range
by saying okay my lower
blue color so you need to provide the
range of your blue color values
and i'm going to say okay my lower blue
color it's
under the array it's going to be an
array
and this blue color array is going to
have
a value of say
65 0
and 0. and i'm going to supply
another upper range now stay with me on
this and explain you what this is
what's happening here and i'm specifying
another
array and this array is going to have a
value
upper bound of 1
255 255.
so i'm having two upper right
so i have a lower bound and an upper
bound and i use this lower
and upper bound to pick out or extract
just the blue color basically what i'm
saying here is
okay i have an image and i'm only
interested
in the blue color which is between these
two values
lower blue and upper blue and this lower
blue is specified
by the hue value between 65 and 110
so my blue color is between 65 and 110
and the rest the saturation and the
variance
is maybe between 0 to 255 i don't care
right now i'm only interested in my u
value
which specifies the color and my color
which is the blue color is between 65 to
110
and this is what opencv will look for
anywhere
where blue color or the hue value is
between 65 and 110
it will extract that and ignore the rest
basically the value of on this color can
go anywhere from 0 to 255
0 to 180 but we are only interested in
65 to 110 okay so we have
decided to find the boundaries of our
blue color
now we are going to be using a range
function to create
a mask okay i am creating a new mask
now this mask is going to have the value
only of the blue color
the opencv has this function called in
range
in range and this range can take these
lower and upper bound range
and return the pixels that lie between
these ranges this range so i say cv2
in range and i you want to
find the range between in the hsv image
using the lower bound and the
upper bound you can see the source image
the lower image
lower bound and the upper bound coming
back we've supplied the image which is
the hsb
we are now supplying the lower bound
which is lower
blue and we are also supplying the upper
bound
which is the upper blue and it's
it will create the mask for us let's
generate this and we can see how
the mask looks like it's it'll be a
black and white image
which will only consist of blue color
so you can see that this is this is the
original image right from here
in the bottom but the upper image only
is specifying the triangle which
represented the blue color
original so it's now creating that mask
is created where
it's only representing the triangle now
i mean let's not display the i am show
original image so if we don't we don't
get confused we can see the image now
only is
creating a mask around the blue color
rectangle
okay so good now the next step is to
create
to use this mask to extract the
original blue color from the previous
image
so we can use a bit wise operation on
this
we can say hey result equal to
cv2 bitwise oh
did i move out of it now
i hope it's visible now so we have bit
wide
and and wherever
your original your mask has an image
wherever your mask is white in color
like this case
wherever the mask is white color it
should return the original color of the
image
and wherever it is black it should just
ignore that
that's what the bitwise hand is going to
do wherever
white color is present it will give out
the original color
and wherever it's black it will ignore
that area
so we'll say okay you're going to be
doing bitwise and
on my image and you're also going to be
pre
you're also going to return the image in
my same image
folder and we are going to use a mask
which is given by our variable here
mask this is my function
and we have defined the result image now
let's display this result
image okay
we are displaying this result image now
let's run this
and let's minimize this a little bit so
we can see so you can see the original
mask looks like this
and the final image looks like this
where it has
extracted the original part of the
image it has the blue color
similarly if you were interested in the
different types of colors
you need to specify the different lower
and
upper range values so like we did lower
blue here
instead of blue we can say lower hue
and upper here because we are
actually converting or we are actually
using
our playing with the hue values so we'll
say upper hue
and lower hue so let's run this back
again to make sure our code is fine we
did not break anything yes everything
seems to be working fine
and we also don't need to display the
mask anymore
since we know how the mask looks like
basically a black and white image
and you can see that this image is only
representing the blue color
rectangle similarly our original image
had different other colors
like it had the red color the yellow
color and we'll see how we can
extract the different colors with this
lower and upper bound range
we find the blue color triangle
now similarly there are different other
color profiles
which can represent different other
colors that you might be
interested in similarly like we have
blue
we have the red color red color
and you can use the red color by conv by
using our lower
view and our lower q
is equal to again with the np
dot array and this array is going to
have a range
of values between 0 to 20
because this red color is
basically zero by zero it's in the
original
spectrum of it's in the initial spectrum
of the hue value similarly we are also
specifying
upper hue equal to np dot
array and this function goes from 0 to
20
u is between 0 to 20 and our saturation
and variance we don't care it can be
anywhere between 0
to 55. once we have this let's
comment this it doesn't affect our
original part
so we have the blue and now we're
looking into the red color
let's run this and you can see now that
it's only showing the red color
circle so it's extracting it's only
isolating the red color from the
original image
similarly there are different other
profiles
so we had the red color now we can also
look into
green colors now green color also has
its own
lower and upper hue which is given by np
dot array and this function of green
color goes from
46 to 91 now
you might ask how am i getting these
values
how do i know that red color is between
0 to 20
well how is blue color between 65 to 110
similarly how is the upper range of
green color between
46 to 91 this is more
with trial and error and again
opencv also has a function called
trackbar
now i'll show you what it looks like cv2
trackbar
and this track bar it's something which
cannot run on a colab
but you can also but you can run it on a
standalone desktop application
so this track bar basically creates this
kind of a
range track bar and you can change the
values of your color
the red the green and the blue and you
can see what kind of an
output you're getting and that output
then you can take that and then
represent it in your own code
so you know what the upper and the lower
bound limits are
using this trackpad you can always play
with it it's something which is not too
complicated to work with
we will see it in the later future
projects if we ever get to use it
but uh if in case you're interested in
identifying what kind of
upper and lower bounds are you can
always use a track part to run with it
so looking into green color
pink color is between 91 and we are
again not interested
in the saturation and various values
we have let's comment the red color now
and let's run this just for the green
color
so you can now see its green color is
being displayed
very nicely uh now say if i were to
display
all the three colors or maybe red color
and green color together you know the
red color starts from zero
and ends at 20 and the green color on
the other hand starts from 46
and goes to 91. so if i were to say okay
instead of 46 let's put
zero it should give us both the red and
the green color
and maybe some other colors also yes you
can see it can
give out the red color the green and
also the colors
between both of them you're getting this
color also
let's let's change this back again to
where we were
so we have 46 to 91.
now let's come back and now try to
define try to
discuss or identify where the yellow
color is
now again lower blue lower hue
which is given by an np array and this
array this is a numpy array and you're
defining this numpy array
between 21
0 for saturation 0 for variance
and you also have an upper u
and np array which has
21 to 45
and 0 255
and 255 so you can see
it's ending up at 45 and then starting
at 46 for green color
that's the reason you had both when you
tried to represent between
0 to 91 so you were getting yellow color
as well
okay let's comment this and let's
run this and this yellow color
is now being extracted or isolated
so you can see again if i were to change
instead of the 21 if i were to put down
zero it would give us the value
of all the three colors which is the
green
the red yellow and the green
now why is the green missing because the
upper bound is
45 whereas the green color is starting
at 46
so if we were to say okay instead of 0
45 let's
say 0 to 91 and if we were to display
this
you can see that it's also giving all
the three colors
what if we needed the blue color as well
again you can play this value
you can see that the blue color starts
at 65 and ends at 110.
so if we were to change the upper bound
limit to 1 1
0 and if you just run this it should
include
all the four colors that we wanted so
any any color that you're playing with
any color that you're interested in in
your own images
will lie between that range 0 to 180
so identify whatever color you are
interested in and then work accordingly
okay let's convert this back again to
what we wanted
so we needed the yellow color and the
yellow color is between 21
and 45. so if we just needed the yellow
color let's run
this and you can see that it's only
giving us the
yellow color hello everyone welcome to
this face detection
intermediate lesson number two under the
opencv tutorial series
in this tutorial we're going to see how
we can do face detection
and the first thing you want to do is
come here where it says table of
contents
open part one and just before part one
the list is cloning of repository this
is basically just copying all the files
that we need
for this project so we just click on the
play and it will download all the files
that we need
so if you come down to the directory
folder you can see
there is this folder called opencv
tutorial created for us
and under that there is a file section
so this file section has this hard
cascade file
if i maximize this a little bit you can
see that it's
showing her cascade frontal face default
xml
this is basically a cascade classifier
that we are going to use
in order to do our face detection coming
back to the table of contents
going to part two intermediate series
lesson number two
now under lesson number two here we're
going to code
our simple face detection application
it's a simple
four or five line code very easy to
follow so just
stay along with me now the first thing
you want to do is import
opencv so you can see we can do all the
image manipulation for us
i'm going to maximize this a little bit
and remove this so that's easy for you
to see
so you have open cv the next thing you
want to do is import
cv to underscore im show from google so
that we can display our
images right here in the pod back in
this browser
you have google collab dot patches
import oops cv2 underscore
i am show so you have underscore then
you have all the libraries that we need
the next thing you want to do is you
want the library
for cascade classifier and that's
cascade classifiers who are going to
help us
in do our face detection so let's
initialize that
and face cascade
is a variable that's going to hold the
cascade classifier for us
we'll call it as cv2 dot cascade
okay face cascade now you are a
classifier
so opencv has this function called
cascade classifier
and you just need to specify opencv hey
opencv you got the gasket classifier for
us
but i also need to tell you where my
cascade classifier
is located but we saw that it was under
this file
section under the hard cascade frontal
face now this is a very big name
so you can see it's called our cascade
frontal face
with a bunch of underscores in between
very difficult for me to remember
so i will just go ahead and say rename
file and i'll press my ctrl c to copy
the file name
and i'll close this now i do need to
specify
okay i got cascade classifier frontal
face here
however we knew that was not just
the by itself it was inside this folder
called
files so i didn't do need to provide the
file path name as well
which is files so view you have
specified that okay the cascade
classifier is inside the file section
files not just file the file section
and under this hard cascade for default
dot
xml so you can do a lot of mistakes here
so just pay attention
so you have files and then you're
specifying this thing
one last thing is you want to specify
this as a string
because cascade classifier is expecting
this as a
string you want to specify under
quotation marks
and that's done with the fair face
cascade classifier
okay so that's done with the cascade
classifier and trust me i think that's
the
most complex part everything else moving
forward is very easy
now the next step is to read one of the
images that we have
now under this directory here under the
images folder there is a couple of
images
and this image with your person.jpg is
basically a human face
and that's the face that we are going to
use to test our
face detection today we'll call it as
image
okay image now opencv you have this
function called
i am read please read the image for me
and the image is inside this images
folder
and it's called person
dot jpg going back showing you
images person dot jpeg which is
specifying that okay it's an
images.person.jpg file
and once you have specified the image
let's simply display the image so we
know
everything is working out perfectly so
far
so let's run this and it's able to
display
a person's image right here in the
browser for us
coming back here let's the first step
you want to do is
convert this colorful image into a
grayscale
image because this cascade classifier
is designed only and only to run on
grayscale images so you have to convert
that into a grayscale image
and how you do grayscale image
conversion going back to our table of
contents
you have changing image color profiles
if you click on that this section where
we learned
the conversion of color this color bgr
to gray
this is what we are going to use today
in order to convert our
bgr image to a grayscale image
so we'll use that same thing we covered
that in the previous lecture
going back to face detection let's use
our convert color function so we'll call
it as
a grayscale image gray image and
we will use opencv's convert color
function to help us convert our colorful
image
to a grayscale image
so you want to specify the image that
you are using
you also need to specify the type of
conversion you're doing
so since you're doing pgr to create you
are going to let
opencv know that it is
a color conversion and it's converting
from bgr
to gray so this right here
is what we are going to use and now
gray is going to be nothing but a
grayscale image so if i
change this img and instead of that we
display this gray
it should be a grayscale image for us so
you can see now
yes it's a grayscale image displaying
for us
so very simple now this grayscale image
is going to be sent
to this face cascade classifier and this
guy has been
waiting for us to do our face detection
so we'll say okay no more waiting
you're ready to do our face detection so
this face detection is going to be run
through this face cascade and this face
cascade
is now since it's a cascade classifier
it has its own
functions it has its own built-in
functions you see the moment i put
the dot it's giving me a couple of
options convert detect multiscale detect
multiscale 2 3
mt so these are all built-in functions
that
the face cascade classifier can perform
for us
in our case we are simply going to be
using this detect
multiscale and this multiscale is
nothing but
a detection function which can do image
detection for us so let me go back close
this back again i'll show you
a few things so the moment you go into
that function
this function is going to take the size
of the image
also the image file name whatever image
you want
the scale factor basically you're trying
to tell
how big your image is compared to the
original training images
the number of neighbors that it can have
a couple of other flags minimum size
maximum size which are not so much of
concern
but the image the scale factor and the
minimum
neighbors are what we are very much
interested in
go back here now you are specifying the
image
which is the grayscale image then now
you're specifying the scale
factor so the hard cascade classifier
was trained on a couple of images
a group a lot of group of images in the
past
but it was those images were of certain
size certain colors certain shape
so the those training images were of a
different property
and it's very different to what we are
using right now
so you're just specifying that okay my
new image could be
of a scale factor of 1.3
well it could be anything else this is
just a random number that i
chose and it seems to be working but if
you notice that this number is not
working for
your own images just change that a
little bit and play around you'll get
the right resource
next thing is you're specifying the
number of neighbors in our case we do
have
we don't have any other faces in this
image it's only one face here
but we're specifying okay this could
have five because
we're gonna be using the same code to do
some group detection as well
so it seems to be five is working out
even for a single image
but we'll see we have the faces now we
use the face casket classifier to detect
all the faces that are available in the
grayscale image
and this faces has information
about all the faces so this function
is a very important function this
variable has information about
all the faces and let's
draw those faces now we are going to be
using
another function another system that we
learned in the past
and this lesson where we saw lesson
number four
under the basics fold section drawing
shapes and text
if you come here we learned how to draw
a rectangle a line even putting a text
so we'll use one of these functions to
do our
face detection coming back to the
directory oops table of contents coming
down to the face detection aspect let's
come down here
now we will use this faces to draw
the information about where the face is
so
this faces has nothing but the
coordinates so if i print this print
faces let's
comment this it will have information
about
the coordinates of where the face is
but these coordinates are nothing but
the pixel values
of where the bounding box of the face is
so let's come back here now let's we
don't need to print this
we will now use these coordinates to
draw our bonding rectangle but we'll say
okay
for x y
w h so
this information in faces
so what what is that i'm doing here so
this
x y w h is nothing but the coordinates
that are available
inside the faces so the 208 and 73
are nothing but the x and y location of
the
top left corner of the rectangle and
this 161 161
is nothing but the width and the height
of the rectangle
of the bounding box which houses the
face
so coming back here we'll say
hey cv2 you have this rectangle function
which we saw in the previous lecture and
this rectangle function is able to take
the
image the point one and the point two
which is the
top left corner of the rectangle and the
bottom right corner of the rectangle
the color the thickness and the line
type line time it's not something we're
interested in
we'll go under the path of thickness so
yes so we have cv2 rectangle and you are
going to be drawing it
on the main colorful image which is the
img
image instead of the green scale image
now
you are also going to specify the point
1 which is given by
x and y and you're also going to specify
the point 2
which is given by x plus
w y plus
each so you're just going and pointing
it out to the bottom left
bottom right corner of the rectangle
so once you have specified the points
you also need to specify
the color and we'll say okay let's use
green color it will say zero 255
for green and zero for red everything
else is green is zero
except the green color which is 255 we
will also give it a thickness of
size 3 pixel level 3
and it should now draw the rectangle on
the face for us
so let's run this
oops we are still displaying the
grayscale image
instead of the grayscale image now we
can display the
img image which should hopefully have
the
face detection for us you can see that
it's
automatically detecting the face of the
person and it's also drawing the green
colored rectangle
that we wanted in this chapter so it's a
very simple chord you can see it's a
hardly a few lines
the only thing you're doing is you're
doing some cascade classifier
you're initializing the cascade
classifier you're reading an image
you're converting it into a grayscale
image then you're using the cascade
classifier to detect
the faces that are available normally if
you have multiple faces it will go
through
all the faces in the face section
and then draw the rectangle on all the
faces
but in this case in this particular
image the person.jpg image that we used
it it's only of it it has only one
person in it
and that's the reason you're you don't
need to go through all the faces
but if you had more faces this function
will just
loop through all the faces draw all the
rectangles
and then display the output for us so
that's where
the phase cascade classifier comes in i
also have another image called
group.jpg i'll quickly run this for you
so let me change this
in fact let me copy this and
oops let me copy this
so i don't mess up your original code in
case you're going to be running this
and here i'm going to change it to group
dot jpg the group.jpg is now a
different image which has a couple of
people in it instead of just one person
so let's see how this function operates
it's this one is going to take a little
bit more time just because it has
too many faces in it and you will see
that how what's the kind of output
you're going to get here i'm going to
skip this a little bit
so now we can see that the image has
come up here
you can see the amount of images amount
of people are present here
and the face detection that is running
through it let me maximize just a little
bit
we can see the intricacy
of the face detection this is a very
noisy image it has
so many information there's so much of
information here
but it's still able to detect the faces
in this image and this cascade
classifier is very
lightweight it used to be run in the old
camera phones the camcorders the old
camera phones
which did not have any much computing
power unlike the phones that you
used now this gasket classifier was
capable of running
face detection in those small low end
profile
you can see the accuracy the level of
accuracy
that's able to detect yes there are some
misses there are some people who are not
being detected
and some errors and mistakes here but
the most part
it is able to give out the right
information hello everyone
welcome to lesson number three of
intermediate opencv
tutorial series and here the first thing
you want to do is
clone this repository by running this
command over here it will clone the
repository all the images that we need
for this project so once everything is
done
go back and open this table of contents
and go under the lesson number three
shape detection that is what we are
going to work on today
so let's import let's start the project
by first importing all the libraries
that we need
we need opencv we need
numpy which will import us numpy
and b and we also need the collab
version for cv to underscore im show
we'll use google collab dot patches
import cv to underscore im show so
this function i am sure is just for
displaying the images for us
let me increase this a little bit so
it's easy for you to see
we will also make it full screen so we
can
clearly see what's going on so we have
the shape detection and we are just
specifying all these libraries right
here
the first thing is let's read the image
and the image is inside this folder
opencv images and shapes.png
so this is the image that we are
interested in today
and we'll do that by reading this image
for us so we'll say opencv
please read an image and save it into
this variable called img
and you want to use opencv's imread
function
and this function just needs the name of
the file
the file name and the file path wherever
it is located
so it's located inside the images folder
in the directory
and we call it as shapes.png
so this will just read the image for us
we can always test the image whether or
not it
read the right image by using the cv2 im
show function
and we just run this and we see there is
an
error right here so it looks like we
missed something
uh google collab patches from
so we needed to import from google
collab
patches import cv to underscore image no
worries we
fixed it now we can just simply rerun
this and we can see that it's able to
read
the image and it's displaying it here
for us
so good now the first thing you want to
do is
since we're doing shape detection we
wanted to discuss
and identify what kind of shape it is so
we know i mean from a human eye that is
this one is a circle
this is a hexagon this one right here is
a square
this is right here a triangle so we from
a human perspective we know what these
images are
but if you were going to give this
control to a computer program
how would the computer read through all
these colors and
identify these images so of course we
need some sort of
algorithms in order to do this and we'll
see how we can do that
so we'll try to read these shapes and
images
through opencv or image processing
perspective
so the first thing you want to do is
convert this into a grayscale image
and we'll use opencv function convert
color
so convert color cbt color this is just
going to
convert the color from whatever color we
want to whatever color profile we want
so you need to specify the image that
you want to convert this to
so img is the original image and we also
need to specify what kind of conversion
you are doing
so we are going to convert from color to
grayscale so we are going to use
cvt color
bgr to gray
you have bgr to gray and this color
profile is just going to just
convert the colorful image into a
grayscale image we can always use
the cv to im show function to see what
kind of an
output we get and you can see that it's
already converted all the colors into a
grayscale profile
it does have the shape and the
boundaries of the image but it's all
grayscale
okay so we have the grayscale image now
now the next thing we want to do is
understand
some of these functions some of these
images some of these
values in a more clearer way and for
that purpose we'll use
open series thresholding function this
thresholding function
is responsible for converting anything
that you are interested in
anything that your your profile is
interested in into
white and then the rest into black in
color so this is
basically a filter and you can say hey
okay okay
open cv anything which is light like
this hexagon the circle
the square the triangle these are all
lighter colors compared to the
background which is black
so anything which is light please make
that into white in color
and everything else black so i'm not
interested in them i'm
only interested in the white in color
profile for that purpose we use
opencv thresholding function and we'll
call
hey threshold used this opencv function
called
threshold this threshold function is a
built-in function from opencv
which can take the source and threshold
value
and the filters and then convert that
into a black and white
image so it basically filters the image
to the values that you are interested in
so you specify the image which is our
grayscale image
now you want to specify the threshold
values so we'll say okay
anything which is between 50 to 255
because we know white color is 255 so
anything which is 255
and 50 is the lower end and we'll see
50 should be okay in our case and we are
also specifying
the type which is not too much of an
initial we just specified one
and we take care of this now let's see
if we can
display this image here for us so cv2 i
am sure thresh
let's see how this kind of an image
looks like
and you can see that it's already
converted
everything into black and white and yes
it's everything
that we are interested in it's all
converted into one color and the
background is in another different color
so this threshold function has already
used a filter and everything that we're
interested in
it has specified them into one color and
the background into another color
so that's the purpose of this shoulder
so it's converting that
into two different values and now we can
use that
to our advantage so now we have all the
functions that we are interested in we
have all the
images that we're interested in now
let's start reading these different
values
from an opencv perspective so
opencv has a good function called as
find
contours so this find contours function
is a type of function that's
able to go through all these images
and go through this right here you can
see the circle
and it will find all the contour the
outer contour
which differentiates these two colors
the black color and the white color
these are differentiated by this circle
right here
and it will find that contour which is
differentiating
these two colors so these two color
pixel values that are being
changed or being differentiated it will
identify the border
of these pixels so we'll use this
function called
contours and these are just the h
and this thing is nothing but just
specifying the history
and the flag values so we're not
interested in that you're just
interested in the contours and the
threshold
so cd2 find contours
and contours is given by contours so
you're just specifying the different
types of contours that we are
looking into and we are specifying okay
the contour
should be taken out from the threshold
image and you're also going to specify
what kind of contours you're interested
in and this is of course a binary image
since we can
we use the threshold function and we are
now you're going to use
different types of filter and pixel
values you're saying okay it's going to
be between one and two
and uh right now you don't need to
understand you know
these two values it's it's as long as
you're putting one and two it will work
fine you don't need to worry about why
or not so
let's go into understanding what these
contours are
so these contours are just specifying
all these outer boundary of the pixel
value of the shapes
when we have the contours detected
these contours are specifying
information about the
circle this hexagon the square and the
triangle
so it has information it has the
contours for all these
shapes that we see here and we will just
loop through
all these contours and go through the
contours that we are interested in
so we'll say okay for
ponds which are contours or the contours
or for a counter or inside
these contours for a counter which is
so we're just looping through all the
contours
one by one by using the for loop
and you want to identify what kind of
what are the points that are specifying
the contours
so these these are the points in case of
a circle there are too many points
since it's a circular image but in case
of a hexagon you can see
that there are six points that you need
in order to define a hexagon
so this we use a function
called as approximate poly dp which is
able to identify the number of
coordinates or the number of points that
you need
in order to define your contour so
whatever shape you're working with
whatever it could be how many points do
you need in order to
identify or in order to draw your shape
so we have this function
called as approximate quality b which
can
give us an approximation of how many
points
we need in order to define our image or
shape
so we have this function's name is aprox
poly dp and this dp
this dp is defined the dp is actually
the name of the person who invented this
algorithm
and uh his first name starts with a d
and his last name starts with a p
i believe is daniel pickard if i'm not
mistaken
uh my mind maybe i'll put it in the
i'll put some text here to identify
what's the right name of the person
but uh this approximate poly is able to
give out the nerd minim on the number of
points that you need in order to
identify your contour so this
approximate poly
just needs the information about
the contour that we are working with and
it also needs
some sort of an epsilon value this
epsilon value is nothing but
the error or the amount of error oh
you know what they have the name here
it's douglas specker
the douglas specker is the name of the
person who invented this algorithm
and that's why it's called aprox polytp
so this function takes this information
called as an epsilon this epsilon
is nothing but the approximation value
or it could
you could take it as an amount of error
that you're you're
okay with when you're identifying this
function
so uh it's one of the best ways of
identifying or one of the best ways to
denote the function or the epsilon value
is by using the
arc length and the arc length if you
multiply it by 0.01
whatever value you get it will be more
or less
acceptable for our error purposes so as
for now just understand we're just
converting this we're just specifying
the amount of error that we are okay
with
and we say okay arc length and
we see we tell the counter name and
true so
let me encode this on this side so you
can see what's happening so we specified
the contour
this we are specifying the epsilon value
which is given by this
and we're just giving by the arc length
of that contour
and based on that now we need to just
specify okay
maybe it's just going to be whether it's
a closed curve or an
open curve in our case all the curves
are closed so we'll just say
true for close or closed
so we are now specifying all the
approximate value and this approximate
will be able to read all these
contour values and give us the value of
the
each and every shape so let's print this
so we'll see what
what is happening here
so we'll run this and you can see that
it's able to go through
all of these and it's giving us the
points for each and every contour
so now let's see okay we have the up
approximate which is giving us the
coordinates of the shape of the points
and let's uh and these are you can see
it's form of an
array it's an array which is going
through all of these points
and giving us so if we go through the
length of the array
instead of printing the whole array if
you just print the length of your array
you can see
that's giving 4 6 3 16 4.
and i wonder what that is so let's go
back and
print this image or read this image for
us
cv to underscore im show and threshold
and just rerun this again so you can see
that this is a shape
and it's giving us four points which
probably represents a square
and it's giving us six points which is
probably representing the hexagon here
then three points for the triangle and
16
points for the circle because circle is
you need too many points in order to
define the circle
and the last is again four points and
these four points is nothing but the
outer image the whole bigger the bigger
boundary of the image which
it's not visible here since we have the
background of the code and this thing is
all inviting color
but that's the outer boundary so it's
given by four here
so good now you are able to
differentiate and you're going to
identify
okay approximate is able to give us the
length of the coordinates
not only the length of the quadrant also
specify the
coordinates of the points that can
define your shape
so you have approximation and now you're
going to say
okay if the length of approximations or
we can say okay number of points n
is equal to length of approximate
so if if n is equal to
4 then this is a square
so you are reading a square so
once you have the square written you can
draw the
contour across the square and you have
this function
called as cv2
draw contours
and this contours function can draw a
contour of
whatever size or whatever shape you want
based on the values that you are
interested in
so draw contours using the for
you know on the image called img and we
have
since we had this image right here the
original image
img we will draw the contour on this
image we'll say img
please draw the contour using the
contours that we have
with inside the cnp function inside this
in the
variable and once we have this specify
what where or whatever the size or shape
of the contour is
so we'll say zero the contour index
and the color which is 255 for our case
and then the thickness where we're just
specifying
what kind of contour image or what kind
of a thickness it is
but we'll say okay for now we're only
detecting the square
and drawing the contour across the
square and then displaying the image for
us so we'll say cv2
underscore i am sure img
okay we don't need the i am show
threshold function
we're just interested in the img
function and let's
run this so you can see that it's
now fully black in color and the reason
for that purpose
is we are not able to read the image
we have already converted that into a
image here for us
and we are also drawing the image
with the minus one and this minus one
has basically drawn
uh it's it's uh filled the whole
image with the color that we were
interested in
and the image the square was the big
rectangle
the big boundary box of the image
and for that purpose it has colored
everything
into that a black black color or blue
color value
now if we were to say instead of minus
one let's say
five let's see what kind of an output we
get you can see there's a boundary right
here which is
almost blue in color and it's specifying
that it's a thickness
of about five if i were to put 50 maybe
let's run this you can see there's a
bigger boundary which is much more
visible
and it's all there's also a boundary
right across this right
this square box here and you can see
that it has a
boundary of about blue color right
across the
square which is green in color and also
across the big square of the image
now you have the square if we were to
say okay instead of the
four instead of the square i'm
interested in the boundary of the
hexagon let's run this and you can see
that it's drawn a
boundary across the hexagon so we are
using the approximate function using the
length of the approximate you can
identify
whether it's a hexagon or a square or
whatever it is
since we put n is equal to six we'll say
it's a hexagon and we'll reduce the
thickness of this say
to maybe 10 and we'll rerun this
and it's able to draw our contour across
the hexagon
and it can also write down that yes
print this is a hexagon
so this function can now tell us that
this is a hexagon
now once we have this
i will say we have a
hexagon here
so we have a hexagon here now it's able
to decide
tell us that this is a hexagon okay good
now let's go through all of these so if
lf n is equal to
we had the triangle which is given by
three variables
you say okay this is a triangle
and we can print triangle okay we found
a triangle
and we can also draw the triangle by
using the contours function
and on the same image with the contoured
value that we
found and here in this case we will use
a different color
we'll say okay maybe you can
specify the contour index and we will
use a different color
so zero comma 255
to zero so it'll be a green color
contour for a triangle
and is there a triangle blue in color
yes so we can use a green color
rectangle triangle
and we'll give a thickness of about
maybe three size
and let's run this and see if we can
see a green color boundary across the
triangle
so yes there is a boundary of green
color right across the triangle
which is very good now once you have the
image
now you're specifying okay so lf
if n is anything greater than or n is
equal
to or nine so that's basically your
circle
so this is a circle
and print we found a
circle cv2
dot draw contours
circle on the img image function
using the contours that we are
interested in
and then you just specifying the index
we'll put it as zero
no nothing nobody's on that and then the
color profiles
in this case we will maybe use 255
255 i think this is a pink color let's
see what kind of an output we get
and let's run this you can see oh it's
giving us a yellow color circle
boundary right across the circle so you
have everything
just the square is left so square
we will say okay
lf n is equal to four which is given by
its square
this is a wire
say print e
okay good we are also going to draw the
function
contours img
c and d
c and d and you specify the index now
you're also specifying the color
we want we say 255 comma 255
comma 0 and a thickness of
3 size let's run this
and it's giving the sums of an error
because we missed
the bracket here instead we put it to
here
so it should be fine now and yes you can
see there is a
boundary right here and there is a
boundary over here
as well so you are specifying you are
able to differentiate
all these colors and it is able to
differentiate and
see what kind of a shape it is and you
can identify what kind of
shapes that we are working with in this
particular
image so the if we
do a quick recap on this we did a quite
a bit of things in this
lesson we looked into the thresholding
value so where we can
threshold we can filter the image of a
grayscale image into whatever color
profiles that you are interested in
and you can also use the find contours
function which can
go through the image and find all the
different types of contours
that are representing the shapes in the
image
and then using the approximate poly dp
you are able to identify the points
the approximate points that you need in
order to identify in order to draw your
contour once again
and once you have the contours then you
go through all of the
length of the approximation and based on
the length of the approximation
you're identifying what kind of a
contour with is it if it's a six
you know if it's a six coordinate
contour it's a hexagon if it's a three
coordinate contour then it's a triangle
similarly
you can identify it with a circle or a
square so
this is basically helping us to identify
the different types of shapes
from an open city from an image
processing perspective
hello everyone welcome to this part
three of the opencv tutorial series
here we are going to try and attempt to
do a project
this is about tracking a ball you can
see this video in front of you
the ball is moving around and the idea
is
to track the movement of the ball at any
point
from a human perspective we know where
the ball is moving it's moving right
left right in random fashion but how
would you do that
from a computer vision perspective how
would you make a
computer understand where the ball is
moving so let's get into that
so the first thing you want to do is of
course import
opencv let me make this a little bit
big maximized is everything
so it's very easy for you to read okay
we have import cv2
import numpy as nd
and from google collab
patches import cv to
underscore the intel before we do all
this
let's go ahead and clone the repository
if you go into the table of contents
and open cv six the first
step just above the part one is where
the github repository is and we do want
to clone this repository
this will allow us to access some of the
project files
that we are going to be using in this
particular
project so you have the opencv tutorial
folder
and inside this you will see this videos
folder
and in this videos folder there's a
video file called video.mp4
and this is what the file or the ball
tracking file is that we'll be using
okay let's come back to the table of
contents let's go into a project
which is the tracking above let's
continue our coding so
right now we have just imported the
libraries that we need
the next thing is let's open the video
file
that we just saw so we can call opencv
has this
function called video capture
which is basically able to read a video
file for us
so we'll create a capture variable
called cap
equal to cv2 video capture
and this video capture is able to read a
video file
or even a webcam for that matter if you
wanted to read a webcam
of course you can't do this on a collab
you can do this on your own desktop
computer
and if you just put down zero it will
start reading the default webcam that's
connected to your computer
but instead of that let's read a video
file that we have
here in this call app so we have it
another folder called videos
slash video.mp4
so coming back again just to make sure
we are under the opencv tutorial folder
and inside that there is this videos
folder
slash video.mp4 that's the file that we
are going to read
through our capture variable this
capture variable is capable of reading
through every frame of the video file
for us
and the way we do that is by reading
hey capture give me a frame from your
video file
and cap has this function called
read this read function is able to read
through the video files and then give
out
the frame that we want but now a video
file
is consist of multiple
frames it has millions of frames
hundreds thousands
many frames that are stacked on top of
each other
then when they play in a sequential
format it looks like a
video so if we just read it once it'll
just give you the first frame
if you read again frame equal to cap dot
read
it will read the second frame similarly
if you read it again it'll read the
third frame so you have to keep going
and throwing and
reading through all the video frames
that's a very cumbersome
format and you really don't know how
many frames there are
so instead of reading them individually
we will read them through a
vial and we will open up a while loop
will you say hey while loop please start
reading the video file for us
but you want me to you want to read the
video files
only and until the videos
start or spitting the frame files
so it should read only until the videos
have
enough frames to read and once the video
comes to the end of it
file you should stop reading otherwise
you'll be running in an infinite loop
so we'll say file cap
is open
and this flag is capable of reading
whether or not there is something
reading through the video file
or not and then now
we will read the frame we'll say frame
equal to cap dot read
so it will read through all the frames
of this particular
read function it will go through all the
frames that are available in the video
file
and then give it in our frame folder
now opencv also allows us to do some
debugging
it allows us to make sure what we read
is good or not so it has a flag and
we'll call this
the red fact flag and this flag is
capable of
letting us know whether or not there was
a frame
read or not so if
there was a good frame and if a real
frame came out of this video file
then this red will be equal to true
otherwise it will be false stating that
no there was no frame red so you don't
need to take care of anything
the frame is nothing so this red flag
helps us also keep a checkpoint stating
that a
if is there a frame or not and if there
is a frame continue with
the next of next process of the project
but if there is no frame
then don't bother so we'll keep a if
statement will say
if red is false
don't bother don't bother the while loop
don't bother continuing with the project
just break out of it
and this is a condition that we will
create just reading the red flag
this flag is able it's whether or not
there was a success or not
of whether a frame is red or not that's
all we're doing here
and this frame is now going to be read
through all the frames of the video file
and subsequently sequentially it will
have all the frames one by one
now let's see what we what we should be
doing with this
frame file this frame file
we are interested in identifying the
color
of the object and we are identifying it
we are also interested in identifying
where the object is in the video
so we lit in the previous projects
in the previous lessons we looked into
color detection
in this color detection we saw how we
could detect
particular colors like you had the
yellow color the green color the red
color
now we know our ball in this particular
video is of
yellow color so we can maybe use this
particular chord
we can create a mask we can do some bit
wise and
and find the position or where the
yellow color is located
that's a cool cool thing to look into
now
coming back we'll use that same system
for our current project
and we will do some yellow color
detection
and for that purpose what do we need to
do first thing we have to do is convert
the color
into a hsv image
again the reason i'm going through this
is because we have already covered this
in the previous
lessons and if you need you can always
go back to the color detection color
changing profiles
and you will understand what we are
doing here so we are now converting it
into a hsp image
and we use cv2 color
bgr2hs
let me bring it here so you can see that
it's
now converted into a hsv image from a
rgb or a bgr
image in opencv format to hsv image this
hsv is now
able to help us detect the yellow color
specifically
and we saw there was a lower bound and
upper bound of hue
and we will use that here so let's go
back to this code
and you have the color detection and
it's easy to copy and paste
the colors that we saw here we have the
lower
hue and the upper hue and we'll copy
this i'll press the ctrl
c button and coming back
to where we were oops the table of
contents we want to go into the project
folder and here we will paste
what we need here this needs to be a
little bit
indented so here lower hue is
representing the lower bound of the
yellow color
and the upper hue is representing the
upper bound
of the yellow color the next step we
want to do
is create the mask and the mask would be
given by
using the cv2 in range function
so in range is going to look into the
image and wherever the hue value
lies between these two ranges and the
hue saturation and various values lies
between this range
it will give out all those pixels in a
different
color so it will highlight those pixels
for us particularly
so we'll say okay cv2 in range function
do your in range magic on my
hsv image using the lower heel
and the upper hue range that i have
created for you so good job
you have created the mask you've now
identified the yellow color specifically
in the video
good now what is the next step next step
is to identify
where this yellow color is
residing and for that purpose we used a
function
called find contours and we did fine
contours
just in the previous function if we go
right here
in the previous function we did draw
contours
draw contours fine contours so
this this is the previous lesson that we
covered where we were doing
shape detection when we were using fine
contours to identify the different
shapes that are available different
colors
and then also draw those contours and we
will use some of these functions in our
project as well so coming down coming
back to the table of contents
project coming back to this place
so we have the mask and we have
now going to create all our contours
so the contours function we will create
okay
contours and on whatever x
the contours function is able to give us
we're not interested we are only
interested
in the contours that find contours
function is going to help us find
so there is a function called cv2 find
contours contours function is now going
to help us in identifying the different
contours that are
available in the image and this function
needs the mask that we just created
it also needs some sort of functions
that are
inter that are going to specify what
kind
of a contour detection it's going to do
so in this case
we are going to be using the pre
function
and we call it as the cvt retr
tree this is just understanding these
are different types of contour
detections
and we're just using a specific type for
our project it doesn't matter
it's it's a simple contour detection
that we're doing here
and it's not going to affect what type
of contour detection you use
and this the approximate
approx simple
so these are different types of filters
that are used a different algorithm
altogether and we will be just using
that
to detect our contours once we have the
contours detected
well good the next thing we want to do
is
then try to identify these contours are
so we'll say okay for now i don't know
where the contour is
so i'll say that contour has a center
point which i don't know and for now
i'll put it as just
none now if my frame
has contours so if my length of contours
is greater than zero which means that i
have contours in this
otherwise it will be zero so if my
contours is greater than zero
yes let's go about and identify where my
contours are located
and for that purpose we will first
identify
which is the maximum the biggest contour
in my image
and for that purpose we'll say hey c
which is the maximum contour
use the max function of python to detect
which is the biggest contour of all the
contours
and you can use the key function
when for how do you identify which
contours are big
the biggest you are going to use the cv
contour area function
the cv2 contour area
is able to give a give you out the
different types of contours and their
areas
and it will give out the maximum size of
the contour
and you can store that under this
variable called c
once you know which is the biggest
contour good
now let's find out where this contour is
located
so we in initially we detected that it's
the center of
none but now let's try to identify where
exactly what is your coordinate so now
we can use a tuple called x comma y
which is going to be the center
coordinate and the radius
and opencv has this function called
minimum enclosing
circle and this minimum enclosing circle
can take a contour whatever contour you
give and in our case we're going to keep
this contour called
c and it's going to take that contour
and identify what would be that
circle what would be that minimum circle
that can
enclose the whole contour and what
the circle is defined is by defined by
the center
point and the radius that is the circle
which will be enclosing
this contour that we have here so now
you know where the center is
you know where the radius is so very
good
now we also i want to identify
where exactly the moment file is
so we have the moments which can be
given as
m equal to cv to
moments so this is another way where you
can identify the center of the quad
in the contour by using moments moments
is nothing but
uh specifying where the center of the
mass
is where the centroid or where the main
center of the
contour is located and for that purpose
we'll use a try function because it's
prone to errors
and we will say hey try to find the
center
and i'll say center is equal to
there is this formula and it's going to
be
it's going to sound a little bit
confusing here but stick with me
what you're just basically identifying
is
the moments of different types of
contours of different
location of the different coordinates of
the contour and based on that it can
identify
where the center or where the centroid
of that contour is located
and that formula is given by int
moment
and this is an array which is given by
1 0 which is nothing but the corner one
corner
and then you are also dividing this by
moment which is given by
m 0 0 so these are two moments which we
are just defining
and that's the x coordinate similarly
the y coordinate
is given by in
moment
and specifying which moment is this the
next
coordinate and then you're also dividing
this
by the base which is given by
m and you have
m 0 0. you're just defining where the
center of the
coordinate is but once you have the
center
now you can also identify
where to draw these centers so we can
draw the center
cv2 circle good
and your frame you're going to draw on
the frame the original frame that we had
and you're going to draw using the
center of the image
good so we have the center
and we're going to say okay the radius
of this
circle is going to be say 10
and we are going to give a color of
maybe blue color
255 0 0.
and we're going to fill this
for the thickness
thickness is going to be minus 1 which
is nothing but
specifying that the whole car the whole
circle should be
filled with this color okay good so now
we have drawn
the circle now this circle
this center is specifying one location
one point of the ball now we are
interested
in identifying all the different types
of
contours that can be available so uh you
want to store
the center of this ball at every
instance
so for that purpose let's define an
array
an open array will say ball
is equal to an open array right now we
don't know what this ball is going to
have
but this ball is supposed to have all
the coordinates of the center of the
ball
at any instant of the video so this ball
array is going to host or have the
center coordinates of the ball
wherever or whenever it is moving in the
video so we'll say ball
dot append append is just
adding to the array
append the center which is the
coordinate of that ball
so you just right now storing storing
the location of the center
into the ball array so good
and if there is an exception
go ahead and pass we don't want to
bother about it now
we have the center of the coordinate we
drew the circle
at that instance and we are also
appending the center
which is very good now let's use this
ball array to draw
the track or the movement of the ball
so for that purpose we'll say if the
length
of ball is greater than 2 because
the reason i'm saying greater than 2 is
because
you want to draw a trap a track is
nothing but a line
and the line can be defined only by two
points
a minimum of two points so in order to
draw a line you need to have at least
two points
and for that purpose i'm saying i'm
asking hey ball
are you length of 2 or greater
if you're 2 or greater let's go ahead
and draw
so i'm just going to draw this now
for i in
range of i
in range 1 to length of ball
so i'm just going to loop through all
the elements all the center coordinates
of the ball
right from zero to the length of the
ball
and we're going to say let me put the
colon here and we'll say draw the line
or the track that i'm interested in on
the frame
using ball's initial coordinate which is
the minus one
which will be the zeroth or the index
zero and the next point which is the
ball
ball i between these two coordinates
between these two center points
go ahead and draw the line that i need
and give me a color of red
i will say zero zero 255
and a thickness of say five
okay so now you're able to draw a line
perfect
now this is where we are able to show
that
yes our opencv project is able to draw
not just
detect where the circulars but at the
all at the same time also
draw the line showing where the ball has
moved so very good now how do we
take this information how do we show it
to the end user
that we were able to do this since it's
a video file
if you start displaying it here on cola
it'll be a big mess
instead of that we will not only we will
read this video file
but we'll also save it as a video file
and opencv allows us to create videos
so using a video writer function
so we'll call it call a variable like we
call the variable capture to read
videos we'll call a variable called
output
or out and we'll say opencv
use your video writer function to
write a video file for me and for that
purpose you're going to create
an output avi file
and this output api file is going to
have the type of the video that we are
interested in you're going to
store all the new frames that you just
created
into that so we'll say okay very good
i'm going to create this output dot avi
file
but what kind of a video file do you
need different types of video files
there's the there's different types of
compression of video files i should say
so there are there is the mg mjpg
which is nothing but moving jpeg moving
jpg
images so we'll use that and there are
different other types of compressions
and we will use mjp g
which is moving jpeg we're going to say
cv2
video writer and this
four cc oops
four four
cc this four cc is nothing but the video
codec that we are interested in
and in our case we'll say m
j
b
g oops capital g
so we have mjpg which is the type of
video coded that we are interested in
we are also going to specify the number
of frames per second
in our case it will be 10 and we also
need to specify the
size of the video and the original video
that i had created the video.mp4 that we
used
that was at a resolution of 1920
by 1080 so this create the same video
file
same size you can use whatever size you
want
but just so because i'm doing a screen
recording if i do something lower it
might come out very bad on the
screen so i'm saving it as a 1920
by 1080. now this output file
oops it's jumping out okay
so this output file is able to write
whatever frame that you are interested
in in this
output.avi folder or avi file
video file so we have this output
function
like we use the capture function and we
use capture dot
read to read through all the frames
similarly
this output function is capable of
writing the frames
so we can say out dot write
frame and this out dot right will just
simply
write the frame that newly created here
into the output.avi file
and it will loop through all the frames
until this while loop is finished until
the red flag saves
no more frames available you went
through all the frames so you're done
now until it does that it will go
through and write all the output frames
for us
and once everything is done it will go
ahead
and you can release the output file
i think this should be indented a little
bit on the left side
because you're doing it in the if length
contour side
if you want to do this once it's
out of the if statement at the final end
of the while loop once you've done
all the manipulations that you want to
do on the frame
and then just simply write the file
onto the output.avi good
now let's go ahead and run this let's
see if we come across
any errors
and it's taking a few seconds it's
running through all the frames for us
okay so it seems to have run and we can
now open this file and we can see
under the videos not on the videos under
the output
main or opencv tutorial folder you have
the
output.avi and i can simply click
here and press download and it will give
you
this output for us
hello everyone welcome to project number
two of our opencv tutorial series
here we are going to try to attempt face
recognition
so for that purpose the first thing you
want to do is going to run time
and this is the link which will already
be there in the description for you
just go ahead and click on change run
time
and you want to make sure you are under
gpu and then just save
because for this purpose we would be
using open
the gpu cloud from the collab
and i'm going to maximize this a little
bit so in order for you to go into the
project too
if you're going to the contents page and
you have projects
right here on the part 3 section and we
are under
page recognition part so once we are in
this
section we want to run this particular
code
here we are basically cloning the
repository
the face recognition repository and we
have some images and some files that we
are going to be using
for this particular project we are also
going to be installing
the face recognition api and
this was i believe designed by adam
gateke that's the name of the person if
you just google
face recognition i'm just going to
google
and we'll do adam base recognition
so this is considered to be one of the
one of the easiest one of the fastest
and
one of the most accurate face
recognition libraries out there
and it was developed by this gentleman
and we are going to be using it
in our project right now so
coming down here uh once we run this
thing it will go ahead and clone the
repository
it will also install the face
recognition library for us
and we are also asking collab to change
the directory to face recognition
that we can access the files directly
so it'll take a few seconds and here in
this section
now you can see there is a face
recognition folder
and right here in this section you can
see
all these files are now available for us
to test
so this project is basically divided
into three steps
one is cloning the repository installing
all the dependencies that you need for
this project
the second is encoding finding the
encoding profile
of the face images the third is
using those encoding profiles to
now detect unknown faces
so we'll go into the basics of each of
them and try to understand what it is
so basically a face has its own
properties
a human face the way a person looks is
defined by
their eyes the shape of the eyes the
distance between the eyes
the nose the size of the lips
the play of placement of the ears
compared to the
rest of the face so these are all
features
that define a person's face and encoding
is just using those features
in order to create a profile for a
person
and those encoding details are specific
to that person
so it's not going to be common it's not
something which can be replaced with
another person's
encoding a person's encoding profile is
his own his or her own encoding profile
and we are going to be using that for
our project today
so the first thing you want to do is
import face
recognition library that we installed up
there
we are also going to be using numpy
today
numpy as nb and before we go into
further details
let me maximize this a little bit also
move this guy up so it's much more
readable for us
a little bit more i think okay perfect
so import numpy as np we are also be
queuing could be using google collapse
cv to underscore im sure so that we can
display the images here in the collab
and for that purpose we will be using
google
collab patches and from there
import cv to underscore
im show we might also use
of course opencv so don't forget about
opencv that's the bread and butter of
this project
so once we have opencv and all these
libraries
imported for us we will now go ahead and
create
the encoding profiles for each face
images
so if you go into the project folder
under the face recognition
you can see there are some images like
the donald trump image
elon musk image earthworld jeff bezos
and these are all images of people who
we already know
and these other set of images right here
unknown
unknown unknown unknown these are all
images that
the computer or the program does not
know
and we will be using these images to use
for face recognition in the next step
so now for now we will use donald
trump's image
and elon musk image and jeff bezos image
to create the encoding profile
so the first step is creating the
encoding
profiles and for that purpose let's
create the encoding profile for face
one face number one and let's call this
maybe
elon musk's face number one and we will
call
the facebook ignition library up there
hey face recognition library please come
to our help
and we want you to imme load this image
file
of elon musk i have elon musk in my
project
folder and it's called elon
it does let me come back here it's
called elon
dot jpeg and you just use elon jpeg
to load the image file for us and
good good job okay so once
face recognition has loaded the image
file now we will also
request our face recognition library to
create the
encoding profile for us we will say
phase one
your encodings are given by
face recognition please face recognition
library come back again
and we need your help this time to
create
space encodings
and codings and for that purpose
we will call phase one use the encoding
profile from
face one and once we have
face one you're gonna call okay
only use the add a zeroth element of the
face
one that's now created the
encoding profiles of phase one encodings
perfect similarly let's create the face
encoding profiles for the other
gentlemen
and for that purpose we'll just copy the
code from here
and paste it here do another paste here
now this one we will call phase two
okay paste three base three
we will change this to phase two it will
change to
phase three and instead of elon we might
say
donald trump and that's the file name
donald trump the next is jeff bezos
given by this spelling
so come back here and instead of this
we'll call
jeff bezos dot jpg
so it has now created the encoding
profiles
for all the three images let's bring
them in an
array so that the program can later call
them
individually so we'll we'll say i will
create an array called
known face encodings so these are the
encodings that the program
already knows and we will call them
inside an array okay
so under this profile we'll call face
one encoding comma
phase 2 encoding
comma face 3 encoding
good so this is my known face
encodings now i will also give these
encodings
names in the same order so we'll say
known face
names and these are the names of our
people
who we are training them oops okay come
down here
so we'll say the first guy is elon musk
the second person is donald trump
and the third person is
jeff pesos okay
so we have all the three images we have
created the encoding profiles
and now we have all the image names also
inside an array so whenever this
encoding one is called
it will refer to elon musk whenever
encoding two is called it will refer to
donald trump
similarly for check pesos so in this
section we only created the
encoding profiles now coming down to the
next section
this is creating the run face
recognition so we are now going to
use those encoding profiles to create
and start
running the face recognition aspect
so let's call let's use one of the
unknown images that
we have we will probably use unknown el
and el is basically the abbreviation for
elon musk
do is donald trump er is earth rule from
here
and je is jeff bezos
i don't know why i left it as je and you
might also
notice a spelling mistake here just be
mindful of this particular image
it's already already an error so
i'll try to remove it in the repository
later on but for now
for the purpose of this video we'll roll
with it
now the first file name we will call
okay let's read the first file and we'll
call the elon musk's
image which is to one here unknown el
dot jpeg and we'll call unknown
el camino we're gonna test you
and to see your who you are and whose
name you carry so you have file name
and we'll say this unknown image
is right here for us oh
it looks like colab doesn't like us to
use gpu runtime
it's giving us an error but don't worry
because very soon we are going to be
using your gpu collab
and at that point point they won't be so
angry with us
but let's come down so we are now
reading this unknown image of elon musk
and we will use space recognition
dot load image the same thing that we
did here
in fact we might copy this whole section
from here and we will just
load this image that we grow this
function we have here
so we'll say load image file and
we'll use the file name that we created
up here
perfect now we have unknown
image to draw recording calls this image
as something that we are going to be
using to write down
in fact we don't need to draw this image
let's call the encoding profile for this
guy
so we'll say okay where are your face
locations and where are your face
encodings so you have your face
locations which are given by
face recognition
dot face locations
using the unknown image that we have
up here
now we are also going to be creating the
encodings
and we'll use the encoding function face
encoding so this new image that we just
uploaded
is going to have face recognitions
encoding
and face recognition
face encoding
unknown image
and face locations
okay so we have now created the
encoding for this unknown image very
good
so let's now try to compare this face
encodings with the
encodings that we already have here
for that purpose we will now use a for
loop
for and we'll first zip
the face locations and the face
encodings
so we'll do zip face
locations and face
encodings the reason for that is because
we want to
compare both of them together so we have
face encoding
and these face locations and face
encodings can be compared to two
different formats
also so we'll say face locations will
give us
the top the right
so these are the top right bottom and
left
corners of the face so you have bottom
and left so this is referring to the
face
locations which we will get it from this
zip file
and we also have the face encoding
for individual
you have the face encoding and the face
locations
including this for the individual faces
and this is just the array
called face encoding so you're reading
through each one of them looping through
the for loop
once you have that now we will try to
create a match and we try to
compare our face encoding from here
to the face encoding that we already
know from here
so let's go ahead do that for us
we'll say matches and matches is equal
to
the comparison between the face encoding
of this new image
versus the face encoding of the images
that we know
already come here
face recognition
dot com here and this is
space function so it's going to compare
the faces
from our known face encodings
and the face encoding that we have here
perfect now initially
we will call our face your unknown
phase as unknown unknown
i don't know initially we call it as
unknown because later on
once the program is able to identify or
recognize whose face it is
it should automatically replace this
name with one of the names that we have
here okay coming back
now we are trying to compare the
distances
from the comparison that we created here
and say
face distances which is equal to
face recognition dot
phase distance
known face encoding
comma phase encoding now here we're just
creating again
that distance and then now we'll drive
using this
distance we will try to now identify
which one is the best for ourselves
coming down
here we'll say the best match
index now this is the index of these
three images so this is zero
one two so you're just identifying which
index items
we will say it is given by the
numpy of minimum distance
between the face distances so all the
phase differences
but it's identifying all the phase
differences and
now it will give us the least face
distance we will say
okay the least face distance from
the face distances array will be my best
match
index okay perfect now if matches
best match index
is available give me the name of
our known face names
so we'll call you just call this known
face names
and we'll say the best match index
is your new name so this is
basically the space recognition aspect
so you're first identifying the phase
distances
and from the phase distances you will
come to know which is the minimum which
is the least
distance between the original phase and
the unknown phase
that distance will be considered as our
will come to know
our index and we will use the matches
that we use here
to then call that particular face name
and we'll use our known face names array
to iron to get the name of the
real person once we have the name of the
person
now we can go ahead and draw the
bounding box
on the face and also put the text so
we as the user can identify who this is
so you we will use opencvs draw
functions which is the rectangle
and the put text function to put down
the text in the bonding box on our image
we'll say cv2 rectangle
unknown and you're drawing it on the
unknown face
here the unknown image in fact let's
read the
unknown image that we have here we're
reading it through the file name
we will also read it through opencv
we'll say unknown
image to draw and this function that we
will use
cv2
file name here we are
reading it in the opencv format so
opencv we can use this image
to draw our rectangle open
cd here come here put it down here
once we have the opencv image you can
draw the rectangles and the rectangles
are defined by the
bottom left or the top right corner so
we say left
top right
bottom perfect so
now you're defining the color you'll say
green color 0 to 55 0
and a thickness of 3 it will take care
of the drawing of the rectangle for us
similarly we'll now draw the write the
text of the person that we know
we'll use the unknown image to draw here
and we'll write the name whatever name
that we want to put by using this name
string we'll say name
and we will say let's write it on the
top left corner of the
rectangle which is given by left
top but we will give it a little bit of
indent
on the top so we'll say minus 20 it's
just above the
top left corner of the image and opencv
has certain fonts that we can use so
we'll use the basic font which is the
font hershey
simplex one zero
color we'll give it as maybe red color
and we will use the thickness of two
and the line format of double a
cv2 line underscore
this will just simply write the text for
us
once everything is done once the for
loop is also completed
we will ask our collab to please go
ahead and display this
unknown image to draw that we just
created here
so once we have this thing opencv should
go ahead
and run this so we'll go ahead and run
this
and it looks like there is an error here
the error says
invalid syntax and it is
probably because we did not say where
are we getting this from
so we should say face encoding top right
bottom
in z
we have to say in zip and that should
take care of
our error looks like there is still an
error and they are not
happy because we put down too many
rectangles at most
six arguments and it looks like we gave
them eight arguments
how come do we have the unknown image oh
did we
say rectangle instead of rectangle we
should have put
put text because we are putting up a
text here
and that should take care of our thing
so we can now see
that it is able to detect the person and
it's also able to put the
bounding box on it and if you go ahead
and open this folder
and open the unknown el folder here
you can see the original image
is right here and this is the
face recognition image so let's try some
other image
we have a couple of other options we'll
open the unknown
which is basically donald trump's image
and we'll see if the file is able to
detect it for us we will say unknown do
here so it can read this new image
and it's able to draw the bonding box on
donald trump's face
this is able to do the face recognition
aspect and you can see it's pretty fast
it's able to do it
almost in real time now this is
something which is done in collab now if
you want to do the same thing on a
desktop or through a webcam the same
thing can be applied
where we are reading a file name instead
of that you will be supplying it
through a webcam and you can use a file
a while loop
a true while loop which would
continuously loop through all the images
of the webcam
and then pass this as a function this
whole code right here can be made as a
function
we will say okay
def and you can say function from
function
and you can pass the image that we want
and instead of this image we'll say
file name so we can then replace this
file name
with here just uncomment this instead of
taking it from here we just call this as
a function
you bring everything in this as part of
it
as part of this particular desk function
so we'll say okay you're part of this
dev function and once we have it here
we can now instead of show displaying it
here on the browser for ourselves
we can then return this variable and
that will go to
go back to the desktop where who's that
while loop who's calling
the images to return go back
and undo our changes
because that is something which we
cannot do here in cola
but just an idea if in case you are
interested